Je vais vous lire les premiers paragraphes du chapitre 6 de la confession de foi
pour faire un peu les résumés de ce qu'on a déjà couvert en tant qu'étude
dans nos expositions sur ces chapitres.
Donc l'exercice qu'on est en train de faire, c'est de ne pas aller tout de suite directement à la confession de foi,
mais de passer d'abord par l'exposition des principaux textes bibliques
pour que quand on fait la lecture de la confession de foi,
ces choses soient plus fraîches dans notre compréhension
et qu'on soit plus sûr que les phrases qui nous sont présentées comme les résumés de l'enseignement biblique sur ces thèmes
soient des phrases qui sont évidemment tirées d'un contenu biblique.
C'est pour qu'on soit habitué avec ces textes,
mais on les fait aussi de manière très intentionnelle
car ce sont des portions des écritures qui sont particulièrement sous attaque
dans leur aspect historique, littéral,
car lorsqu'il les confessions des fois ont été rédigées,
il n'y avait aucun doute que cela devrait être le traitement du texte biblique.
Et malheureusement, sous la pression de la culture actuelle,
il y a beaucoup de déroutes.
Et donc c'est important pour nous de revenir au texte base,
au texte biblique, la base suprême d'autorité pour nous,
afin que nous puissions mieux comprendre les paragraphes de la confession de foi.
Donc, j'ai voulu les paragraphes 1 sur la chute de l'homme.
Donc, bien qu'il y ait Dieu, il a créé l'homme droit et parfait,
il lui a donné une loi juste qui était en vue de la vie s'il avait observée
et qu'il ait menacé des morts s'il transgressait.
L'homme n'a pas gardé longtemps cet honneur.
Utilisant subtilement les serpents,
Satan séduisit Ève et par elle, il séduisit Adam,
qui sans contrainte sur lui,
transgressa volontairement la loi de leur création
et les commandements qui leur avaient été donnés
en mangeant du fruit défendu.
Il a plu à Dieu de permettre cette chute
dans son conseil sage et sang,
puisqu'il avait déterminé de l'utiliser pour manifester sa gloire.
Donc, j'espère que maintenant,
en lisant ces paragraphes,
les souvenirs des leçons qu'on avait déjà couverts
soient venus sur vous.
Donc, ce qu'on voit dans ces paragraphes,
en commençant par la fin,
il a plu à Dieu de permettre cette chute
dans son conseil sage et sang,
puisqu'il avait déterminé de l'utiliser
pour manifester sa gloire.
Donc, quelque part, cette phrase est une protection
qui est fondée sur les chapitres précédents
de la confession de foi.
Donc, on a déjà étudié directement,
explicitement sur Dieu
et ça nous protège en arrivant à l'épisode de la chute
de ne pas douter de la puissance de Dieu,
de la sagesse de Dieu,
de la bonté de Dieu,
de la justice de Dieu.
Car on avait commencé par les bases inébranables.
Ces paragraphes sont en train de traiter la Bible
comme écriture, comme écrit sans,
d'où il tire les principales leçons
à propos du péché, de la chute
et des conséquences de la chute,
les châtiments.
Il est en train de tirer clairement
d'une interprétation littérale
des Genèse.
Donc, quand il va citer ici,
subtilement les serpents
utilisés par Satan,
donc c'est un serpent littéral,
utilisé par Satan, etc.
Donc, clairement, un texte qui traite de cette manière.
Donc, on revient à cette étude qu'on a faite
sur les Écritures tout au début.
Et dans la description
de ce qui a été la chute elle-même,
on voit de manière très claire
ces deux études qu'on a faites
sur chapitres 1 et 2 de Genèse
pour nous considérer l'état original
et mieux comprendre
quels étaient ces pactes
que Dieu avait fait.
Donc, c'est-à-dire Dieu
qui a quitté Adam,
qu'il a créé en extérieur
du jardin des dents
et qu'il a inséré
dans cette relation plus intime
pour manifester clairement
que non seulement il a été créé
en soi-même l'image des dieux,
mais de donner à Adam
le privilège de réjouir davantage
de cette image des dieux
par une relation plus intime avec Dieu
et suivre les paramètres,
les motifs des dieux
lorsqu'il a fait les jardins des dents,
afin qu'Adam et Ève
puissent développer,
selon ces paramètres,
leur mission en tant qu'image des dieux
dans leur interaction avec la création.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Oui.
Et donc,
en ayant inséré Adam et Ève
dans cette église,
dans ces sanctuaires
qui étaient les dents,
Dieu, il était en train
de donner aussi l'opportunité à Adam
par ses pactes
dans cet environnement,
une opportunité
qu'il puisse manifester
sa soumission volontaire
en étant motivé
pour une grande récompense,
que cet état d'obéissance
envers Dieu
ne soit pas un état d'obéissance
tout simplement naturel
ou automatique,
mais une opportunité
de se soumettre volontairement
à la parole des dieux,
d'exprimer une soumission volontaire,
une allégeance totale,
une confiance totale en Dieu
par ses pactes.
Donc,
ce n'était pas
les fruits en soi
qui produisaient la mort,
mais c'était des fruits
qui représentaient
ces pactes
gracieux des dieux
envers l'humanité
qui étaient déjà
dans un état séminal parfait,
mais qui pourraient
encore évoluer
dans son intimité,
dans sa connaissance des dieux,
dans sa soumission volontaire,
dans son obéissance,
non seulement
à la loi interne
et naturelle des dieux
en nous,
en tant qu'il est parfait
à l'image des dieux,
mais à cette loi externe
qui nous donne
la possibilité
de faire osage
à l'origine,
il existait,
de notre livre arbitre
afin de manifester
une soumission volontaire
à la parole des dieux.
La motivation suprême,
c'était l'arbre de la vie
qui rendrait cette condition
qui était déjà parfaite,
encore plus parfaite,
même si mystérieux,
et de manger du fruit
de la connaissance
du bien et du mal,
c'était d'expérimenter
véritablement les mals
par expérience
et donc la mort
et il n'y avait pas
une distinction
de soi-même
visible dans les fruits.
Tous les fruits
qui Dieu avait créés
étaient agréables à vue,
ils étaient bons à manger
et donc ce n'était pas
du tout une tendance
de la part des dieux
tyrannique
ou une tendance
des privations
ou capricieuse.
C'était quai pour donner
à l'homme
l'opportunité
de progresser
dans sa relation
avec Dieu
et de progresser
dans son état
des béatitudes
et de rendre éternel
en ayant traversé
positivement
ses tests,
sa condition
des béatitudes
encore plus élevées.
Donc on sait très bien,
l'homme a choisi
sous l'influence
de Satan
l'arbre du fruit
de la connaissance
du bon et du mal,
c'est-à-dire
la rébellion
contre Dieu,
il a choisi
l'autonomie,
les péchés,
l'insoumission volontaire.
Il a choisi
d'être douté
de la parole
des dieux,
douté
des bonnes motivations
des dieux,
il a choisi
de créer
ses propres lois.
OK ?
Et donc cette conception
biblique des libertés,
c'est la conception
d'être capable
de vivre
à la hauteur
du but
pour lequel
on a été créé,
car un dieu bon
nous a créé
à son image
et notre bien
n'est qu'étrouvé
en vivant
en accord
avec les buts
de notre existence.
Vivre
pour réjouir
surtout de l'intimité
avec Dieu
et fonctionner
selon les particularités
de notre création
à son image.
L'homme en fonctionnant
en tant qu'homme,
la femme en tant que femme,
leur interaction
complémentaire,
avec la création
pour accomplir
cette mission
de fonctionner
comme image
de dieu dans le monde
et au-dessus
de tout ça,
cette intimité
avec Dieu
en paix de conscience,
en ayant accompli
joyeusement
tous les buts
de notre existence,
accomplir les buts
suprêmes
de nous présenter
devant Dieu
avec la sensation
d'avoir accompli
la bonne œuvre,
les buts
de notre existence
et réjouir surtout
de cette relation
avec Dieu.
Et donc,
on a vu
comment la chute
a eu lieu
et nous allons
maintenant
considérer
quelles sont
les conséquences
ou les résultats
de la chute.
Les versets 1 à 7
qui décrivent
la chute
nous ont montré
dans un certain sens
ce qui est,
on va dire,
ce qui sont
les paramètres
ou les motifs
de presque
toutes les tentations
et la Bible
dans sa concision,
elle nous aide
à considérer
quelles sont
les progressions
vers les péchés.
Donc,
cette convoitise
interne,
ces désirs
qui vont marcher
dans la direction
d'une concrétisation
externe.
Dans les cas
d'Adam et Ève
qui étaient
dans une position
des perfections
originales,
la première
ou le début
de la tentation
vient de l'extérieur.
C'est Satan
qui va porter
la tentation.
Mais,
nous qui sommes
déjà dans une condition
de péché,
nous ne sommes pas
qui est tenté
par Satan,
nous sommes tentés
qui est par notre chair
aussi parfois.
Mais,
les progressions
sont les mêmes.
Donc,
des fois,
des mauvaises pensées,
des mauvais désirs
qui se développent.
Et des fois,
les désirs
pour des bonnes choses
mais avec un rapport
incorrect
ou exagéré
envers les choses.
Et donc,
il y a cet aspect
de la subtilité
de la tentation
et qu'en même temps,
au fur et à mesure
qu'on commence
à baisser les gardes
et douter
de la parole
des dieux,
de la bonté
de l'autorité
des dieux,
de la justice
des dieux
et douter même
des punitions
qui Dieu avait promis
qu'elles allaient se passer
si on tombe
dans les péchés,
à partir de là,
Satan
ou la chair
vont chercher
à devenir
de plus en plus
osés
dans leur confrontation
des dieux.
Donc,
on a vu
que la progression
du péché
passe par l'érosion
de la confiance
en Dieu,
par l'omission
de nos responsabilités.
Donc,
l'homme était là
mais il n'a pas empêché
la femme.
La femme était censée
à respecter
l'ordre reçu
par Dieu
à travers son mari.
Elle était aussi
dans l'omission
à cet égard.
Il y a cet aspect
d'une espèce
de sensualité
plutôt animale,
des appels
qui sont faits
à la chair.
Et l'ambition
idolâtre,
c'est ce qui fait
l'appel
à cette autonomie,
créer ses propres lois,
douter des dieux.
Mais,
notamment,
les sommets
ou l'expression
maximale
du péché,
c'est une transgression
externe
consommée
à l'extérieur
contre
la parole
des dieux
explicitement
donnée
comme ordre.
Donc,
transgression.
tout ça,
on voit l'inversion
de l'ordre originel
de l'homme
et la femme
en tant que créature
des dieux
et des relations
entre l'homme
et la femme
en eux-mêmes
dans leur complémentarité.
La femme
qui va prendre
l'avance
et l'homme
qui,
au lieu de la protéger
et de conduire
la décision,
va plutôt
se soumettre
à cette direction
de la femme.
Et donc,
on voit l'inversion
de l'ordre
entre l'humanité
et Dieu
et entre
les relations
complémentaires.
Et donc,
la nature
du péché
est une nature
de méfiance,
d'anormalité,
c'est d'agir
contre les normes
des dieux,
des normales.
c'est une question
d'injustice
et donc illégale,
c'est d'aller
contre la loi
des dieux.
C'est une question
des mensonges
car la vérité
des dieux
va toujours prévaloir,
même si Ève
a douté
des menaces
des morts
et si elle a cru
avec des promesses
vides,
des vies
par Satan.
Donc,
c'est un mensonge.
C'est toujours
idolat,
c'est de nous mettre
ou mettre un autre
à la place des dieux
pour nous donner
des conseils.
C'est maléfique
en soi
et donc produit
de la destruction
et de la mort.
C'est impi
car l'impiété
est la définition
de ne pas aimer Dieu
tout simplement,
de ne pas imiter Dieu.
Donc,
c'est de choisir
d'imiter un autre.
C'est de la fausse liberté
car en cherchant
une espèce de liberté,
la femme a retrouvé
et l'humanité
a retrouvé
l'autodestruction
et donc,
à la fin des comptes,
c'est tout simplement
la désordre.
C'est les chausses
duquel Dieu
nous avait tirés
pour ordonner
l'univers
à notre faveur
et nous ordonner
à partir de la poussière
dans sa direction
et nous sommes
en train
de nous désintégrer,
de nous désordonner
quand on voit
les péchés.
Donc,
voilà quelques pistes
qui vont nous aider
quand on étudiera
la doctrine
sur les péchés
pour définir les péchés.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a
les péchés ?
Ok ?
Donc,
on va arriver
à ces considérations
dans l'exposition
doctrinaire.
Mais,
deux textes,
je suis en train
de vous aider
à tirer
quelques conclusions
très naturelles
à partir de là.
Donc,
en ayant considéré
la chute,
on a considéré aussi
ces parallèles
entre la chute
et la tentation
de Jésus.
Et donc,
dans la tentation
de Jésus,
on ne va pas revenir
dans l'ensemble
du texte
ni dans les détails,
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
les mêmes motifs
utilisés par Satan.
C'est intéressant
de remarquer
la formalité
avec laquelle
cette tentation
de Christ
était une tentation
représentative.
Donc,
il débute son ministère
par les baptêmes
des gens.
Il prend sur lui
la responsabilité
des traités
avec la coupabilité
de nos péchés.
C'était les baptêmes
des répentances.
Donc,
Jésus n'avait pas de péché.
il était en train
de porter sur lui
la responsabilité
de mener jusqu'à la fin
sa mission.
Donc,
cette obéissance
parfaite
dès sa naissance
pendant son enfance
dont nous avons besoin
pour qu'il puisse
nous créditer
une obéissance parfaite
en toutes choses,
elle était en continu
jusqu'à sa mort.
Par contre,
cette phase spécifique
des tentations,
c'était après son baptême,
les Saint-Esprits
descendent
pour manifester
son onction sur lui
et lui a dirigé
par les Saint-Esprits
pour être tenté
au désert.
Et donc,
c'était une tentation
qui a beaucoup de parallèles
entre la tentation
d'Adam et Ève.
Les stratégies de Satan
vont dans la même direction.
Il va porter
la convoitise
de la chair.
Jésus va jeûner
pendant 40 jours
et il sera tenté,
il aura faim
quelque part.
Et Satan,
la première tentation,
va appeler
la convoitise
de la chair,
les désirs de manger
tout simplement.
Sauf qu'il y a
beaucoup des contrastes
entre la situation
parfaite,
les générosités
et provisions
qui avaient Adam
à l'origine
et Jésus
qui est dans un lieu
désert
et qui a faim
après 40 jours
sans manger.
Donc,
c'est une tentation
un filet en plus
intensifiée
afin que Jésus
soit pleinement
approuvé
et qualifié
pour être
notre substitut
victorieux.
La deuxième tentation
qui va faire appel
à cet orgueil
de la vie,
donc tout comme
pour Adam et Ève,
c'était
être comme Dieu,
avoir la connaissance
du bien
et du mal.
Donc,
on voit comment
Christ est tenté
à s'élancer
pour goûter
de cette protection
divine
orgueilleuse,
détenter Dieu
sans aucune
motivation réelle,
aucune nécessité réelle,
de la même manière
que la femme
a voulu faire
ses sauts
dans les vides
et démanger ses fruits
et tenter Dieu
en se mettant
en position
de mourir.
Vous,
la tentation
de Satan,
certainement,
vous n'allez pas
mourir.
OK ?
Donc,
avec Jésus,
jette-toi
du haut du temple,
tu n'as pas besoin
de traverser
tous ces sacrifices
qui ces temples
représentent
par rapport
à la mort
que tu vas traverser,
saute et les anges
vont réunir
te chercher.
La même tentation.
Et donc,
ensuite,
la troisième tentation,
démontrer
tout ce que les yeux
peuvent convoiter,
la convoitise des yeux,
comme nous dit
Jean dans sa lettre,
la convoitise de la chair,
la convoitise des yeux
et l'orgueil de la vie.
Et donc,
là,
c'est tous les rois hommes,
tous les privilèges.
Donc,
c'est la même récompense
que Christ aurait
en traversant
son œuvre de rédemption,
donc la croix,
mais par un raccourci.
Et donc,
ce sont des promesses
fausses,
des bénédictions
par les compromis.
Donc,
on voit comment
Christ a été approuvé.
Les sauts d'approbation,
c'est car à la fin,
Christ,
il va insister
sur la résolution
de se soumettre
à la parole de Dieu,
à la volonté de Dieu.
Il répond à chaque fois
les distorsions de Satan
avec sa fidélité
envers la parole de Dieu,
craindre l'Éternel seul,
adorer et jurer
pour lui seul.
Ensuite,
avant,
il avait parlé aussi
des vivres,
non seulement des pommes,
mais de toutes les paroles
qui procèdent
de la bouche de Dieu.
c'était de vouloir démontrer
sa soumission volontaire
et glorieuse
en tant qu'enfant parfait,
de faire usage
de sa liberté
de son libre-habitre
pour se soumettre
pleinement
à la bonne volonté,
à la bénéfique volonté
de Dieu,
à la juste volonté
de Dieu.
Donc,
une fois qu'il est approuvé,
là oui,
ses promesses
commencent à s'accomplir,
les anges viennent
les servir
et donc,
on voit comment Christ
a accompli
cette étape pour nous.
Et donc,
c'était important
de considérer
la tentation du Christ
pour comprendre
comment cet aspect
de représentativité
est important.
Adam,
lorsqu'il est évoqué
dans cette tentation,
dans ses premiers pactes,
il est évoqué
comme
les représentants
de l'humanité.
À plusieurs reprises,
en Genèse,
il est appelé
tout simplement
mâle,
ok,
homme,
mais parfois
il est appelé Adam
et ça,
c'est vraiment
pour désigner
les représentants
de la race humaine,
la race humaine
qui était
et qui habitait
en lui,
c'est l'humanité
plutôt.
Et notamment,
dans ses pactes,
c'était Adam
qui était évoqué
comme notre représentant.
Et Romain 5
va nous aider
à comprendre
qu'en Christ,
notamment par cette tentation
aussi au désert,
nous avons
les nouvelles Adam,
c'est lui qui peut être
les représentants
pour notre salut
car Adam,
les premiers Adam
étaient les représentants
au moment
où on a échoué.
Et donc là,
on voit
de manière très claire
l'importance
de voir
cette tentation
de jeunesse
comme historique aussi
car Christ
est également historique
et il a dû traverser
cette tentation
pour accomplir
quelque chose
qui était en train
de racheter
ce qui a été échoué
avec Adam.
Donc,
on passe
au résultat du péché,
on va lire
à partir du verset 7
à nouveau
pour considérer
quelles étaient
les premières conséquences
du péché.
Donc,
ce que nous allons
remarquer,
c'est que tout comme
l'être humain
a été créé
dans un état parfait
mais encore
quelque part
séminal,
c'est-à-dire
s'ils étaient approuvés,
ils pouvaient encore
améliorer leurs conditions
en rendant éternelle
la non-possibilité
éternelle
d'échouer,
de tomber
et d'approfondir
sa relation
avec Dieu.
OK ?
Et donc,
il était déjà parfait
mais encore développé.
C'est intéressant aussi
de remarquer
que dans la chute,
les conséquences
du péché,
elles sont radicales aussi
mais elles sont
séminales,
c'est-à-dire
ni toutes les conséquences
qui retombent
sur l'humanité
après la chute
sont des conséquences
ultimes
et immédiates.
OK ?
Donc là,
on savait qu'on allait mourir
certainement
en mangeant cet arbre
mais on n'est pas,
on est en train de mourir
mais on n'est pas mort
immédiatement après manger.
Donc,
je vais vous donner
d'autres exemples
à cet égard
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
ces aspects un peu
séminales
dans le sens
où les choses vont
se développer encore
comme une sémence
qui se développe.
OK ?
Donc,
les conséquences.
Il y a quelques conséquences
que nous observons
de manière très naturelle
est automatique.
OK ?
Et instantanée.
Donc,
verset 7,
juste après qu'ils mangent,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Les yeux
des l'un
et des l'autre
s'ouvrirent.
Ils connurent
qu'ils étaient nus
et ayant cousu
des feuilles
des figuiers,
ils s'enfirent
des ceintures.
Donc,
qu'est-ce que nous
trouvons déjà
tout de suite
dans ces passages ?
Les premiers résultats
de la chute,
c'est une espèce
de prise de conscience
de leur chair.
Et donc là,
ce n'est pas tout simplement
du corps
mais la chair
qui se manifeste.
Donc,
on se rappelle
du langage
de la nudité.
Donc,
un peu avant,
les moments
où ils étaient créés,
ils étaient nus.
OK ?
Mais,
ils n'étaient pas
en train de les noter.
C'est-à-dire,
c'était une innocence.
Leur corps
était tout simplement
un véhicule
parfaitement équilibré
pour l'expression
de leur âme.
L'image des dieux,
donc la cohérence
de leurs sentiments,
de leurs affections,
ne permettait pas
de la nudité
soit perçue
au vu
comme elle est pour nous
comme un symbole
des immoralités sexuelles,
des disformités.
Et donc,
à partir du moment
où ils sont en train
de pécher,
il y a ce désordre
qui a lieu tout de suite
et les premiers résultats,
c'est qu'ils deviennent
conscients.
Donc,
avant la chute,
ils étaient inconscients
de leur nudité.
L'homme et la femme
étaient tous deux nus
et ils n'avaient
point honte.
Mais dès qu'ils ont péché,
cette honte est apparue.
Et immédiatement,
ils essayent
eux-mêmes
de trouver une solution
pour leur péché
ou pour cette nudité.
Ils cherchent
à se couvrir.
Et donc,
ils prennent des feuilles
des figuiers.
Ce n'est pas la couverture
qui suffira pour eux.
On verra ça plus tard.
Mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que la Bible,
elle est en train
de donner
une grande importance
spirituelle même
à cet aspect.
il y a une liaison spirituelle
entre la corruption
du péché,
la chute
et ces désordres
qu'on a
vis-à-vis
de nos corps,
à la chair.
Et des fois,
l'Église,
elle insiste
de manière très exagérée
par rapport
aux particularités
des péchés
de la chair
ou elle est très lâche
par rapport
aux sons
qu'on devrait avoir
vis-à-vis
à l'osage du corps
à tous égards.
Mais c'est important
de nous rappeler
que la Bible ici,
elle est en train
de donner
une place
d'importance.
C'est la première remarque
qui est enregistrée
devant nous.
Ils étaient nus
dans un premier moment
et ils n'avaient pas honte
et immédiatement
après les péchés,
ils perçoivent
qu'ils ne peuvent plus
être nus.
Et c'est cette sensation
qu'on a
avec nos péchés,
avec nos pensées
pécheresses
qui sont liées
aux péchés du corps.
Ils sont liés
aux péchés
de la sensualité
ou de la chair.
Et donc,
nous percevons
que maintenant
ce véhicule
qui est un véhicule
pour l'expression
de l'âme,
il devient pour nous
un véhicule
des hontes
qu'on essaie
de se couvrir
car il manifeste
notre coupabilité
dans la pratique
et dans les faits.
Mais cette tendance
de vouloir nous cacher
démontre
qu'en cherchant
à nous cacher
à l'extérieur,
on essaie plutôt
de nous cacher
à l'intérieur,
à la corruption
du cœur.
Et donc,
c'est au cœur même
de la condition
pécheresse
de l'homme
qu'il est coordonné
par Dieu,
qui dans une certaine
mesure
reflète la gloire
de Dieu,
est devenue
une source
de troubles
et de honte.
Maintenant,
il y a
une espèce
de désordre
dans
dans cette espèce
de trépied
qui est
l'être humain.
L'être humain
est un être intégral
qui à la base
avait cette spiritualité,
c'est-à-dire
cette connexion
avec Dieu,
notre perfection morale
qui nous connectait
avec Dieu
et qui nous donnait
ce qu'il fallait
pour faire un bon usage
de l'âme
et du corps.
Et donc,
il y a une portion
immatérielle
comme on a vu
dans la création,
dans l'être humain,
qui peut être
distinguée
dans sa composition
entre esprit
et âme,
même s'ils sont
dans la plupart
des temps
synonymes
selon la Bible.
Mais,
lorsqu'il dit
que nous sommes
morts spirituels,
c'est que cette
connexion avec Dieu,
cette piété
a été perdue
et maintenant,
nous nous sentons
poussés
par les tentations
de l'âme
et les tentations
du corps
qui nous dominent
parfois.
Par exemple,
l'orgueil,
l'arrogance,
l'essence
des justices propres,
les désirs
d'autonomie,
ce sont les péchés
de l'âme.
Mais les corps
font aussi
beaucoup de pression
pour qu'on soit
toujours en train
de satisfaire
les convoitises
de la chair.
Et l'illustration,
c'est comme si
on était entre pieds
parfaitement équilibrés
lorsqu'un autre esprit
n'était pas mort
avant la chute
et qu'il avait
la capacité
d'équilibrer
l'intégrité humaine
et aujourd'hui,
on est dans
ces désordres.
Et donc,
il y a,
c'est des règlements
et donc,
chaque individu
de soi-même
et envers soi-même
se trouve déjà
en trouble
immédiatement
après la chute.
Donc,
il y a cette notion
du corps.
Mais ce n'est pas
que ça.
Verset 8,
« Alors,
ils entendirent la voix
de l'éternel Dieu
qui parcourait
les jardins
vers les soirs
et l'homme
et sa femme
se cachèrent
loin de la face
de l'éternel
au milieu
des arbres
du jardin. »
Et donc,
là,
on voit
un mouvement
par rapport
à Dieu
qui est radicalement
à l'opposé
de ce qui était
le mouvement
jusqu'ici.
L'être humain,
par nature,
avait pour
sommet de sa joie,
il avait
par couronne
de sa semaine
cette rencontre
avec Dieu
tous les samedis.
et les moments
les plus glorieux
qu'il avait
à chaque jour
vers les soirs
ou vers les moments
du refroidissement
de la terre,
c'est-à-dire
vers la fin
de la journée,
Dieu venait
visiter
quotidiennement
Adam et Ève.
Et c'était
les moments
les plus importants,
les plus glorieux.
C'était comme si
nous,
on essaye
de préserver
cette discipline
de dévotion,
mais imaginons
nous,
en fait,
imaginons-nous
avoir
ces dévotions
quotidiennes
avec ces niveaux
d'intimité
sans aucun péché,
aucune résistance
et cette réjouissance
pleine
de la présence
de Dieu
constante
dans nos vies.
Et donc,
on voit
de manière très claire
cette
prochaine
réaction
envers Dieu
ou ces prochains
résultats immédiats
du péché
qui nous voyons
clairement
et qui nous pouvons
classifier
qu'ils étaient
coupables.
Dès qu'ils ont
mangé,
ils ont su
qu'ils avaient
mal agi,
ils se sont
sentis
condamnés,
ils ont eu
de la honte
et leur réaction
était
une crainte
négative
des dieux
et la perte
de leur communion
avec Dieu.
Donc,
avant,
la voix des dieux
était attirante.
Avant,
la présence
des dieux
était attirante.
attirante.
C'était
l'aimant,
les magnés,
l'aimant
les plus puissants
pour l'âme humaine.
Maintenant,
et ça,
c'est quelque chose
qui va marquer
toute la race humaine,
l'idée
de Dieu
va nous faire
plutôt vouloir
nous enfuir,
échapper.
Pourquoi ?
Car on a
cette coupabilité
qui fait partie
de la race humaine
à cause
de nos péchés.
et donc,
personne
n'a besoin
d'informations
pour chercher
à les convaincre
qu'ils sont coupables.
Rien que
ces efforts
continuent
pour supprimer
l'idée des dieux,
pour s'enfuir
de la présence
des dieux,
démontrent clairement
qu'ils nous sommes
entourés
à l'extérieur
par des évidences
d'un Dieu bon
qui a créé
toutes les choses
pour notre bien,
d'un Dieu parfait,
d'un Dieu d'ordre,
et nous sommes
inexcusables,
c'est l'argument
de l'apôtre Paul,
donc personne
pour être condamné
n'a besoin
de la Bible.
La révélation naturelle,
elle est suffisante
pour nous condamner
tous.
Et pourquoi ?
Car ces mondes
qui nous entourent
nous donnent
toutes les évidences
de l'existence
des dieux,
d'un Dieu bon
et d'un Dieu sang.
Et en plus
des évidences externes
qui devraient nous pousser
à vivre pour sa gloire
et vivre en reconnaissance
envers Dieu
pour tous les biens
qui nous entourent,
nous avons la conscience
interne
qui nous condamne,
qui démontre
que nous avons
une conscience,
qui garde encore,
même si
quelque part
corrompu
et quelque part
cautérisé,
mais garde
dans nos consciences
les imprentes
des dieux.
Et donc,
lorsque nous sommes
condamnés
par notre propre
conscience,
ce sont des évidences
que tous les êtres
humains sont inexcusables.
Quelle est la réaction
des êtres humains
devant tel monde ?
Quelle est la réaction
des êtres humains
devant sa conscience ?
Comme ils ne connaissent
pas l'évangile,
comme ça ne passe pas
par notre pensée
car aucun être humain
ne pourrait...
Voilà pourquoi
on a besoin
d'une révélation
par rapport à l'évangile.
Voilà pourquoi
on a besoin
de la Bible.
On a besoin
que Dieu lui-même
nous donne l'évangile.
Pourquoi ?
Car,
quelqu'un a déjà dit ça,
même si on avait
la capacité
d'arriver à la conclusion
d'une possibilité
pour les saluées
de l'humanité.
Et la seule possibilité,
on sait très bien
à cause de la révélation,
c'est que Dieu
envoie son Fils
car il faut
qu'un être pur
puisse nous représenter
au lieu d'Adam,
à la place d'Adam.
Et comme nous ne trouvons
personne pur
entre nous,
il faut qu'il soit
Dieu lui-même,
les fils des dieux
et qu'il descende
et qu'il prenne
véritablement
la chair humaine,
la forme humaine
pour pouvoir être
un représentant
légitime
de la race humaine
et qu'il vive
la vie parfaite
à notre place
et qu'il soit mort
à la croix
pour que ça retombe
sur lui
notre condamnation
de l'enfer.
Même si quelqu'un
aurait pu
déchiffrer
que c'est
la seule possibilité
de salut,
personne n'oserait
suggérer à Dieu
de faire
une autre chose.
Donc ça montre
à la une
les besoins absolus
que Dieu lui-même
révèle la manière
du saluement
et que Dieu lui-même
soit disposé
à les faire.
Et donc la réalité
c'est que quand on voit
cette coupabilité
auquel nous sommes
tous exposés
par nature
pour être condamnés
à l'enfer,
aucun autre
comment on a besoin
de l'évangile.
Donc ce n'est pas
les refus de l'évangile
qui mènent les personnes
à l'enfer.
Les refus de l'évangile
peuvent redoubler
leur condamnation.
Mais tous les peuples
et toutes les nations
sont condamnables
sur les bases
de tout simplement
l'évidence
qui devrait
mener une vie
d'obéissance,
de rendre gloire
à Dieu
et de reconnaissance
et au lieu de les faire,
ils sont plutôt
dans la dynamique
de s'enfuir
des dieux,
de supprimer Dieu.
Et c'était la tendance
de nous tous
avant la conversion.
C'est clairement
ma tendance
avant la conversion.
Et c'est intéressant
comment l'évangile,
il est une proclamation
qui va nous donner
un nouveau cadre
d'espoir
et qui nous pousse
aussi à la répentance
d'une manière
plus favorable.
Car si Dieu
est proclamé
dans son évangile
envers moi
comme quelqu'un
qui a déjà pourvu
une solution
pour mon péché,
c'est un Dieu
pour moi.
Et devant un Dieu
pour moi,
je suis encouragé
au lieu de chercher
à m'enfuir
de sa présence,
je suis encouragé
à me répentir
et embrasser
la provision
du pardon
qui me présente.
Et donc,
cette conséquence,
la culpabilité,
fuir des dieux
pointe envers
cette séparation,
la perte
de cette communion,
de cette relation
avec Dieu.
Donc,
c'est une crainte
très négative,
c'est la peur
car la bonne crainte,
elle est toujours
une bénédiction.
Et donc,
on a eu
cette conscience.
Verset 9,
Et donc,
on voit clairement
dans ce passage,
un autre résultat
de la chute,
c'est une position
des condamnations,
une position
des jugements
que l'homme
ne connaissait pas avant.
Non seulement,
il expérimente
des conséquences,
suivez-moi,
c'est très important,
non seulement,
il est en train
d'expérimenter
des mauvaises conséquences
de ses péchés,
comme si on était
tout simplement
devant
une conception
du mal
qui soit tout simplement
la privation du bien,
ça c'est vrai,
mais ce n'est pas
que ça.
Comme les cadres
du pacte
étaient un cadre
des révélations verbales,
un cadre des lois
établies à l'extérieur,
la manière
dont Dieu vient
visiter Adam,
c'est un cadre
des jugements.
Et pourquoi ça,
c'est très important,
car la Bible est explicite
pour nous démontrer
qu'à la croix du calvaire,
Christ n'était pas
en train de mourir
comme les deux voleurs
à ses côtés.
à midi,
les ténèbres
s'emparent
de cet endroit.
Après que tout
soit consommé,
il y a un tremblement
des terres,
il y a les déchirements
du val du temple.
Donc c'était évidemment
un scénario
des jugements
cosmiques.
Tout comme
lorsque Dieu
vient vers Adam,
nous sommes devant
un jugement cosmique,
les jugements
de la race humaine.
Voilà pourquoi
il ne va pas appeler
celle qui a péché
les premiers,
ni celui
qui était le plus méchant
dans ses péchés.
Satan,
il va appeler
les représentants
de la race
les premiers.
Donc Dieu
va continuer
de traiter l'humanité
malgré
la désordre
qu'on avait fait
dans cette
renversion
des rôles,
hommes,
femmes,
etc.
Dieu va continuer
de traiter
l'humanité
selon l'ordre
qu'il a établi.
Il appelle
d'abord
l'homme
pour être
rédévable.
Il était
le premier
responsable
par rapport
au sort
de la race humaine.
Et donc là
on voit
cette représentativité
selon l'ordre
créationnel
et c'est intéressant,
c'est lui
qui réjouissait
de la face
de l'éternel,
de la faveur
de l'éternel.
Maintenant
il a peur.
J'ai entendu
ta voix
dans les jardins
et j'ai eu peur
parce que
je suis nu
et je me suis caché.
Il a été
toujours nu.
Il écoutait
toujours la voix
de Dieu
et maintenant
il a honte
et il a
cette envie
de se cacher
et Dieu
le sait
très bien
mais
il veut
sa confession.
Dieu sait
très bien
ce qui s'est passé
mais il pose
la question
est-ce qu'il
t'a mangé
des larves
dont je t'avais
défendu de manger ?
Et là
c'est un exercice
très important
aussi
car nous sommes
toujours
sous l'excrutant
des dieux,
sous les jugements
des dieux.
Indépendamment
de ceux qui puissent
ou non regarder
nos péchés,
nos pensées,
on est toujours
invités
à traverser
les processus
des répentances
qui soient
les plus favorables
au rétablissement
de notre condition
avec lui.
Et donc Adam
au lieu de
confesser
sa coupabilité
il va
commencer
les coupabilisations,
la rationalisation
du péché,
les débuts
des dynamiques
d'excuses
parce que je suis nu
je me suis caché.
Ce n'est pas
car il est nu,
c'est car il a mangé
du fruit de l'arbre.
Et ensuite,
quand il est
mis en question,
sa réponse
est plutôt
la coupabilisation
de la femme.
Si quelqu'un peut lire
les versets 12
et 13.
vous voyez,
chacun est en train
de pousser
la coupabilité
à l'autre.
Et c'est vrai
que chacun
a une portion
de coupabilité
en tout ça.
Mais c'est important
de remarquer
que c'est déjà
aussi
un résultat
du péché
la victimisation
et la rationalisation
du péché.
Ce sont
des dynamiques
de chercher
des excuses,
de coupabiliser
les circonstances
au lieu
d'assumer
notre coupabilité.
donc,
Dieu ne donne
aucun crédit
à ces excuses
et il commence
à prononcer
les jugements.
Donc là,
on est objectivement
devant
les conséquences.
Et toutes ces conséquences
pourraient être
classifiées
comme
des différents
niveaux
des morts
pour ce qui
concerne l'humanité.
OK ?
Et donc,
déjà,
il y a une punition
radicale
à nouveau
et séminal
à Satan.
OK ?
Donc,
c'est intéressant,
la punition dirigée
au serpent,
l'éternel Dieu dit
puisqu'il t'a fait cela,
tu seras maudit
entre tous les bétails
et entre tous les animaux
des champs,
tu marcheras sur ton ventre
et tu mangeras
de la poussière
tous les jours
de ta vie.
Donc,
c'est intéressant,
il y a un impact
sur l'animal
lui-même.
OK ?
Car cet animal
a été quelque part
profané
par Satan,
il a fait un usage
impur de cet animal
et donc,
il y a cette conséquence.
Donc,
Dieu,
dans son plan éternel,
dans sa sagesse,
va faire d'une sorte
que cet animal
gagne à partir de là
une symbologie,
un symbole
très important
pour l'humanité.
Donc,
même là,
on voit en mesure
des grâces
en faisant usage
de cet animal maudit
pour que nous puissions
par la représentation
de cet animal
à partir de maintenant
mieux comprendre
ce qu'est les péchés,
ce qu'est la tentation,
ce qu'est la manière
de Satan
d'agir.
Et donc,
cet animal,
lui,
il souffrira
un impact
sur son corps.
OK ?
Donc,
on ne sait pas.
Peut-être qu'il avait
des ailes
car l'Apocalypse
va dire
que les dragons,
l'ancien serpent,
possiblement,
ou il avait des pattes,
on ne sait pas.
On sait qu'à partir de là,
il y a eu un changement
dans son structure
pour que la manière
dont il a agi,
où il a été utilisé
pour conduire l'humanité
à sa plus grande humiliation,
ces mouvements
qui Dieu avait fait
avec nous
de nous sortir
de la poussière
et de nous élever
quelque part
à quelque chose
de glorieux
à son image
et en intimité
avec lui.
Donc,
c'est intéressant,
ces mouvements
de vouloir manger
de la poussière,
vous voyez,
d'être gloutons,
d'être gloutons
envers cette création
qui Dieu a voulu élever.
C'est comme s'il était
en train de dire
tu as voulu exploiter
ce qu'il y avait
de plus fragiles
en eux.
Quelque part.
Et tu es en train
d'être vanté
d'avoir attaqué
de la poussière.
Donc,
la punition,
c'est représenter
cette humiliation
et cette convoitise
démesurée
qu'il y avait Satan.
Donc,
l'éternel Dieu
dit au serpent
« Puisque tu as fait cela,
tu seras maudit
entre tous les bétails
et entre tous les animaux
des chiens,
tu marcheras sur ton ventre
et tu mangeras
de la poussière
tous les jours
de ta vie. »
C'est cette manière
humiliante
que cet animal
aura désormais
de vivre
de cette manière,
rebaisser
le maximum
qui est possible
et reconnu
à partir de là
comme une menace
pour l'humanité.
Donc,
imaginez-vous,
bien sûr,
les animaux
n'ont pas de sentiments,
n'ont pas cette complexité
qu'il a,
mais dans la représentativité
pour nous,
il y a quelque part
en didatique biblique
du privilège
que tous les animaux
ils ont
d'être à service
des petits dieux
dans ce monde,
dans les bons sens
de la ressource
où nous sommes
l'image des dieux.
Tout a été créé
pour trouver
leur sens d'être
dans la manière
dont ils allaient
faciliter
et servir
des provisions
pour que nous,
dans cette interaction
avec l'univers,
on puisse glorifier Dieu
et donc là,
il y a un animal
qui va perdre
complètement
ses buts
assez élevés
d'existence
qui étaient
nous aider
à glorifier Dieu
dans ces mondes.
Et donc,
lui,
il devient
les symboles
des malédictions.
Donc,
on voit
bien sûr
qu'en dirigeant
ces conséquences
au serpent,
Dieu est en train
de diriger
ces punitions
à Satan
lui-même.
Donc,
c'est une humiliation
bien sûr
beaucoup plus importante
par rapport
à la réputation,
à la rénommée
qu'aura Satan.
C'est donc
les symboles
des malédictions,
c'est les symboles
d'être
l'opposant
subtil,
séducteur
et lâche
envers Dieu
et les choses
des dieux.
Et c'est
cet aspect
du péché
qui porte
cette contamination
mortelle,
cette capacité
de communiquer
un poison,
d'agir
par la subtilité,
par la prétention.
Et donc,
malgré
sa petite taille,
les petites tailles
des serpents,
ils aiment bien
manger grand,
si on veut dire
comme ça,
même plus grand
que leur corps.
Et donc,
c'est une ambition
qui va finir
de la part des dieux
envers Satan
avec cette punition
envers cet enfer
qui a déjà été
préparé
pour Satan.
mais avec
une humiliation
publique
et la Bible,
elle fait exprès
à plusieurs reprises,
dans plusieurs passages
qu'elle parle de l'évangile,
de comment
Dieu va exposer
les autorités démoniaques
à l'humiliation publique
par la manière
dont Dieu va renverser
la contamination
de Satan.
Donc,
on voit dans l'imagerie
biblique
beaucoup de passages
et beaucoup d'épisodes
comme les serpents
au désert,
vous vous rappelez,
qui avaient été élevés
comme un symbole
des fois
pour ceux qui regardent
ces serpents,
ils seraient guéris.
et on sait très bien
que Christ lui-même
va être intentionnel
en utilisant cette image
pour dire
« maudits seront tous ceux
qui seront pendus au bois »
et lui va dire explicitement
que comme les serpents
ont été élevés
dans les déserts,
lui devrait être élevé
et donc prenant sur lui
la malédiction
de cette contamination
de péché
contre nous.
OK ?
Donc,
c'est glorieux
de bien comprendre,
de bien saisir
les langages de serpents
dans la Bible
tant pour l'humiliation
de Satan
comme pour
l'espoir de l'Évangile
car Christ a dû
devenir malédiction
à notre place.
Donc,
la punition de Satan,
elle est aussi
encadrée
par cette question
du prénom
de l'Évangile.
Donc là,
la séquence,
je mettrai
l'inimitié
entre toi et la femme,
entre ta postérité
et sa postérité,
celle-ci
t'écrasera la tête
et tu lui blesseras
les talons.
Donc là,
on voit de manière
très intéressante
de quelle manière
on voit
un prénom
de l'Évangile.
Donc là,
c'est clairement
Christ qui vient
et qu'à la croix,
il a les talons
blessés,
mais par la croix,
il est en train
de défaire
la contamination
de Satan,
du serpent
et la tête
étant écrasée.
Et donc,
c'est une référence
déjà,
tout de suite
en Genèse 3
de ce qu'on appelle
les proto-Évangiles.
Donc,
c'est l'Évangile
premièrement
communiqué,
la première fois
où l'Évangile
est communiqué.
il est communiqué
à nouveau
de manière
séminaire.
La révélation
de cet Évangile
sera progressive,
mais nous voulons
de manière très claire
que la chose
elle est communiquée ici.
Et donc,
ce qui va se suivre
avec l'histoire
de l'humanité
à partir de là,
c'est qu'il y aura
une transmission
en continu
du péché,
une race contaminée
par les péchés.
on voit
comment la descendance
de la femme
va perdurer
comme la descendance
de la foi
quelque part,
mais la descendance
de l'humanité
sera divisée
entre les descendants
du serpent
et les descendants
de la foi.
Et c'est ça
qui est intéressant
dans la dynamique.
Donc,
on va passer
par Adam et Ève,
donc Cain et Abel,
la première division,
et donc ensuite
Seth,
Noé,
Sem,
Abraham,
et donc là,
c'est la descendance
de la foi
quelque part
et en parallèle,
la descendance
du serpent.
Avec Noé,
on va revenir
en espèce
de reset,
de reboot
avec les déluges,
mais tout de suite
après,
même ces trois fils
sont divisés
entre la descendance
de la foi
avec Cain
à Cain
qui sera
la descendance
du serpent
explicitement
en opposition
à Dieu,
en piété
dans les mondes,
dans toutes les nations
païennes,
et Japhè,
qui sera
un représentant
de la rédemption
des nations
plus tardive,
car les tentes
allaient s'étendre
pour inclure
toutes les nations.
Donc là,
toute l'humanité
est considérée,
mais nous voyons
de manière très claire
tous les longs
de la Bible
cette dispute
et nous voyons aussi
donc cet espoir
envers la femme
et la Bible
elle est très précise.
Donc,
quand on arrive
au Nouveau Testament,
on va se discuter
par rapport
à l'interprétation
de cette postérité.
Donc là,
littéralement,
c'est sémence
et donc
en Genèse plus tard,
il y a aussi
cette question
de la sémence
d'Abraham
et en Galate,
il dit pas
à tes descendants
en pluriel,
mais à ta descendance
comme s'il parlait
d'un seul.
Et donc,
les vrais saluts
n'est pas un salut
qui concerne
tous les juifs
descendants d'Abraham,
mais c'est un Messie,
un descendant
qui y viendrait,
un individu
qui lui-même
allait écraser
la tête du serpent
et en lui,
toutes les nations
de la foi
seraient bénies.
Et donc là,
on voit de manière
très claire
comment,
même si c'est très
séminal ici,
toutes les précisions
de l'Évangile
sont importantes
car c'est un homme,
un nouvel Adam
qui viendra
de la femme.
Donc,
c'est cet Adam-là
qui va passer
à désirer
et à aspirer.
La punition de la femme,
donc il dit à la femme,
« J'augmenterai
la souffrance
de tes grossesses,
tu enfanteras
avec douleur
et tes désirs
se porteront
vers ton mari,
mais il dominera
sur toi. »
Donc ici,
nous voyons
de manière très intéressante
que l'essence
les plus nobles
des lettres
et l'essence
les plus nobles
des relations
ont été
punies.
Donc,
au lieu
de tout simplement
enfanter,
en ayant cette expérience
la femme
d'être
ce véhicule
de multiplication
pour peupler
la terre
avec la joie
de reproduire
l'image des dieux,
maintenant,
cette image des dieux
viendra corrompue
par les perchés,
même si préservant
l'image des dieux
partiellement,
mais en même temps,
ces moments
qui devraient être
un moment
des plans plaisir
deviennent
un moment
des douleurs,
enfantés
avec des douleurs.
Et donc,
les sens plus nobles
et nous voyons
combien Satan
va attaquer
ces principes.
Au lieu
de la formatation
originale
de la femme
se dirige
pour se sentir
réalisée
dans sa vie,
dans la société,
par l'enfantement,
on voit comment
nous sommes
encouragés
à focaliser
sur d'autres
objectifs de vie
avant ça
ou même plus
élevés que ça
et on voit
combien frustrés
nous sommes
à cet égard.
et donc,
même les stratégies
capitalistes
qui vont
combien,
par exemple,
ceux qui veulent
nous vendre
des médicaments
et déplanifier
mieux en pensant
à la carrière,
etc.,
ce sont les mêmes
qui vont plus tard
chercher à nous aider
à avoir des enfants
par la FIV,
etc.
Donc,
c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
combien d'argent
circule
pour exploiter
ces lavages
des cerveaux
qui nous poussent
à penser
d'abord et avant tout
à l'avortement
en pensant à la carrière
et plus tard,
quand on devient
un peu plus mature
et qu'on a des vrais désirs
pour avoir des enfants,
notre organisme,
parfois,
il est tellement déjà
abîmé
par ces médicaments,
pas médicaments,
mais par ces contraceptives
et qui,
finalement,
on est dans une situation
beaucoup plus difficile
pour avoir des enfants
et pour être réalisés.
Heureusement,
par la grâce des dieux,
nous pouvons trouver
les pardons des dieux.
Par la grâce des dieux,
on peut trouver
la réalisation d'enfanté
et des enfants spirituels
et dans la famille
des fois aussi,
mais la réalité,
c'est que nous voyons
dès maintenant,
dès ici,
ces douleurs
et ces conflits
entre Satan
et la descendance
de la femme.
Donc,
c'est très intéressant
car l'essence
le plus noble
de la relation,
ici,
ton désir
sera
ou se portera
vers ton mari,
c'est-à-dire
dans l'original,
c'est tu auras
un désir
d'avoir
ce qui est à lui,
ce qui lui appartient
en termes des rôles,
des relations,
c'est-à-dire lui,
l'échelle,
lui qui devrait
conduire,
lui,
maintenant,
ton désir sera
de prendre sa position
au foyer,
dans la société,
etc.
Et la femme,
donc,
va soit
par une insoumission
ou une masculinisation
de la femme
chercher à occuper
ses postes,
soit par la dissimulation
ou par la manipulation,
au lieu de nourrir
les lignes de son mari,
elle va manipuler
la manière
dont les choses
seront conduites.
Donc,
ça marque
l'histoire
de l'humanité.
Et de l'autre côté,
avec l'homme,
c'est la même chose
car lui,
il va dominer.
Donc,
l'homme va osciller
entre une lâche
omission
en permettant
à la femme
de faire
des travaux
qui,
lui,
il a plus
habilité à faire.
Donc,
c'est une lâcheté
envers elle.
Mais de l'autre côté,
il y a aussi
cette domination
machiste
au lieu
de porter
une conduite,
une direction
aimante
et inclusive.
de prendre
en considération
l'aide
que la femme
devrait être
pour la prise
des décisions.
Et donc,
on voit
de manière très claire
que les jugements
se portent aussi
dans la direction
de l'assimilation
de combien
vont perdurer
ces mêmes
éléments
qui ont contribué
à la chute.
Mais,
dans un sens
très rédempteur,
la femme aura
une réalisation
encore plus noble.
et ça,
c'est vraiment
glorieux
dans la Bible.
Car,
avant,
ils avaient
des enfants
par commission,
donc,
multipliez-vous
au coup
de la terre.
Avant,
il y avait
un sens
de réalisation
en ayant
des enfants,
mais maintenant,
il faut enfanter
par nécessité.
Sinon,
la race
ne continue plus.
Il faut enfanter
par expression
des fois,
car les descendants
viendra
d'un descendant
de la femme.
Et il faut
enfanter
avec un but
encore plus élevé
que tout simplement
multiplier.
On pourrait être
la multiplication
de l'image
de Dieu.
Maintenant,
on est,
quelque part,
la multiplication
pour la rédemption
de Dieu,
pour que les saluts
arrivent.
Voilà pourquoi
l'apôtre Paul,
il dit que toutefois,
la femme,
sera préservée
et sauvée
par la maternité,
par sa mission
des mères.
Et qu'est-ce qu'on voit
dans l'histoire
de l'humanité ?
On voit
l'esclavage
en Égypte,
on voit à chaque fois
l'opposition
des satans
qui cherchent
à décourager
les femmes
d'enfanté
et à tuer
toujours
la descendance,
particulièrement
la descendance
de la foi.
Et les chrétiens
aujourd'hui
qui sont
très timides
par rapport
à leur commission
à développer
leur famille,
à avoir des enfants
plus tôt
et plus nombreux
car ces commandements
n'ont jamais été
retirés
envers
les peuples
des dieux.
Donc on voit
l'esclavage
en Égypte,
la naissance
de Moïse,
la protection
des dieux
et Satan
qui veut
tuer Moïse
et toute la génération
d'Israël.
On voit
la protection
des Moïse,
ensuite en Babylone,
l'ordre des dieux
malgré la captivité
de ses multipliés
de bénir,
mariez-vous
et ayez des enfants.
On voit plus tard
l'idolâtrie d'Israël
lorsqu'elle a sacrifié
ses enfants
en commettant
des avortements
massifs
par les sacrifices
sous l'influence
d'autres religions
et combien Dieu
les a condamnés.
Et on voit
à la naissance
de Jésus aussi
de la même manière
comment Satan
a utilisé Hérode
pour faire les massacres
des enfants
jusqu'à moins de deux ans
à Bethléérin
et la description
d'Apocalypse
qui nous montre
les dragons
qui cherchent
à dévorer
l'enfant.
Donc c'est le même travail
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
et si vous vous sentez
un peu tenté
par les discours
très progressistes
dans nos jours
pour valider
l'avortement,
etc.,
il faut qu'on soit conscient
que cette stratégie
de Satan
est là
depuis Adam et Ève
et pendant toute
l'histoire de l'humanité.
Et la punition
de l'homme,
donc je n'aurai pas le temps
de rentrer dans les détails
de tous ces passages,
mais bien sûr
que ce qui va toucher
toute la race humaine
de manière plus large
et qui va toucher
la création
d'une manière directe,
donc c'est que cette mort
ou cette punition
vient ou survient
à l'homme
comme les chefs
et représentants
de toute l'humanité.
On va revenir
à la poussière
car de la poussière
on a été quitté
et donc on va
de manière très claire
cette mort effective
physique,
on va aussi
la difficulté
de l'homme
d'être celui
qui va conduire
la famille
et les mariages
qui devraient cultiver,
pouvoir,
protéger,
tout sera fait
avec difficulté
car cet environnement
qui servait
à promouvoir la vie,
à faciliter
la provision
des dieux envers nous,
il y aura
cette catastrophe
que cet univers
sera soumis
comme à des otages
de notre rébellion.
Et donc il y a
cette interaction
avec le monde
qui sera plus difficile,
la sueur
pour les travaux,
la difficulté
non seulement
de voir
les bons progrès
et les bonnes choses
mais l'obligation
d'être constamment
vigilant
envers la progression
des mauvaises herbes.
C'est comme un jardin,
les mauvaises herbes
apparaissent,
il y a plein de choses
qu'il n'y avait pas encore
et cette interaction
plus dure
avec l'humanité.
Donc ni toutes
les conséquences
étaient des conséquences
immédiates
même si l'homme
est passé
à mourir
et même si moralement
il a été
immédiatement
corrompu
à la source,
la moralité
n'a pas été
complètement supprimée.
Donc quand on parle
des dépravations
totales et radicales,
c'est-à-dire
qu'on a été
corrompu
dès la source
et donc
toutes nos facultés
sont touchées
et tâchées
par les péchés.
Ce n'est pas comme
si méchants
comme on pourrait être
dans tous égards
mais on est radicalement
séparés des dieux
donc c'est cette mort
spirituelle
qui nous déconnecte
des dieux
et il y a aussi
la préservation
de la faculté homène
mais il y a aussi
une progression
au long de l'histoire
de combien
toutes nos facultés
seront abîmées.
Donc des fois
on pense qu'on est
aujourd'hui plus intelligent
qu'on était à l'époque
d'Adam et Ève
mais c'est le contraire
que la Bible nous présente.
Aujourd'hui
on peut faire
quelques progrès
en continuant
sur les progrès
qui ont déjà été faits
mais quand on voit
la capacité intellectuelle
qu'on peut contempler
dans l'histoire
on voit plutôt
une corruption
une dégradation
mais nous voyons
combien leur intellect
tout de suite
ils commencent à faire
de la musique
à s'organiser en ville
on voit comment
la tour des Babels
était quelque chose
d'expectaculaire
et c'est qu'à partir
du déluge
que nous commençons
à avoir
cette réduction drastique
dans la vie humaine
comme conséquence aussi
du déluge
de l'environnement
et tout ça.
Je n'aurai pas le temps
de rentrer dans tous ces détails
mais il y a certains aspects
qui ont été radicals
et immédiats
et d'autres aspects
qui ont été préservés.
L'illustration
peut-être
qui est la plus précise
c'est des pensées
qui est l'être humain
aujourd'hui
comme les ruines
d'un château
qui un jour a été glorieux.
C'est comme si on était
en train de contempler
des ruines
comme a dit
en puritan
et peut-être
en panneau
en affiche
en disant
ici à cet endroit
un tel roi
si glorieux
un jour à habiter.
Donc on n'a pas
complètement
totalement supprimé
l'image des dieux
en nous
mais on a été
radicalement
séparés des dieux
et la réalité
c'est qu'on est
devant la noblesse
et la cruété
de l'être humain
la promiscuité
et donc nous
par la grâce des dieux
en tant que chrétiens
rachetés
on a été réconciliés
radicalement
avec dieux
et nous progressons
envers la restauration
de l'image des dieux
en nous.
On a des grands potentiels.
Par contre
l'humanité
en soi
dans son état
aujourd'hui
sans dieux
c'est ces ruines
où on peut se dire
un jour
Dieu a habité ici
et c'est ça
les moments
ou les positions
qu'il est Christ
va régagner pour nous
par son œuvre.